good afternoon  i i particularly wanted to say that  my father i suppose the last  uh 70 years has given the most  remarkable devoted service  uh to the queen to my family  and uh to the country and also to the  whole of the commonwealth  and as you can imagine my family and i  miss my father enormously he was a  much loved and appreciated figure  and apart from anything else i can  imagine  and we're so deeply touched by the  number of other people here  and elsewhere around the world in the  commonwealth who also i think  share our loss and our sorrow  and my my dear papa  was was a very special person who i  think above all else would have been  amazed  by the reaction and the touching things  that have been said about him  and from that point of view we are my  family deeply grateful  for all that it will sustain us in this  particular loss and at this particularly  sad time  thank you thank you